et pour les sélecteurs de figurant sur
la liste aucun gros vous avez la parole
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le ministre la
barbarie est à nos portes nous a dit le
ministre de la justice qu'elle
inquiétant affirmation en réalité pour
vous la barbarie ne serait qu'à nos
portes quand des gamins se font tirer
dessus au bataclan des familles se font
écraser à nice que les passants se font
poignarder des profs décapité la réalité
c'est que les barbares sont là parmi
nous et qu'en plus nous n'avons plus de
portes à fermer vous avez tous retirer
mes chers collègues de droite comme de
gauche toutes les barrières toutes les
frontières
ce que vous appelez timidement le
désordre migratoires mais qui est en
réalité une anarchie une déferlante
migratoire
vous en êtes tous responsables à droite
peut-être davantage car je rappelle que
c'est nicolas sarkozy qui a aboli la
double peine c'est lui qui entretenait
les meilleurs rapports avec le qatar
c'est sous sa présidence que
l'immigration a atteint des records
mes chers collègues droite vos coups de
menton aujourd'hui sont autant elle
descend keane audible aujourd'hui les
terroristes bénéficient de notre giron
de notre générosité pour commettre leurs
abominations le bataclan des migrants
le roi est mort en à marseille vingt
clandestins tunisiens l'attaquent de
romans sur isère en avril un réfugié
soudanais l'attaquent de charlie hebdo
le mois dernier un faux mineurs isolés
pakistanais et la semaine dernière un
réfugié tchétchène à chaque fois c'est
la même chose
la même explication la politique
d'immigration marche ictu des français
les terroristes d'importation de tuer
des innocents mais dans la classe
politique c'est le grand silence
impossible pour vous avouer que la
politique d'immigration
loin d'être une chance et un véritable
fléau il faut pourtant la stopper
elles coûtent trop de vies à la france
vous avez épuisé votre crédit
communication monsieur le ministre il
s'agit désormais d'agir pour sauver des
vies malgré les insultes et les
violences le mouvement national auquel
j'appartiens aux alertes inlassablement
depuis des décennies aujourd'hui qu'il
est douloureux d'avoir raison dans ces
conditions vous nous avez dit femme est
diabolisée et haïe pour aujourd'hui nous
donner des raisons en tout alors ma
question monsieur le ministre la voilà
allez vous oui ou non
op l'immigration et renvoyés dans leur
pays ces centaines de milliers
d'étrangers qui n'ont rien à faire chez
nous la parole pour vous répondez tous
venus de l'intérieur monsieur le maire
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur ravier le
moment est trop grave pour faire de la
polémique je suis moi je ne vous vois
pas monsieur s'intéresse lui et moi une
autre oeuvre pour faire de la polémique
et je voudrais pas rentrer dans leurs
réponses avec le même ton que vous avez
posez votre question il n'y voyait pas
la condescendance mais sur le fond je
vais c'est de répondre à votre question
vous évoquez les attentats tous horrible
tous ignoble tous commis au nom d'une
des l'idéologie islamisme radical mais
il est faux monsieur le sénateur et
jeudi devant une chambre qui représente
la nation française veut dire que ce ne
sont que des étrangers qui ont commis
ces actes
sur les 19 derniers attentats
c'est à dire tous les attentats qui ont
eu lieu depuis 2017
j'essaie d'être le plus objectif
possible neuf étrangers
vingt-deux français il faut monsieur le
sénateur que bien sûr on pose la
question des étrangers qui sont en
situation de radicalisation et je
partage d'opinions j'imagine la plus
communément partagée par le bon sens
populaire et par ceux qui les
représentent qu'il faut expulser du
territoire national toute personne qui
trouve le profondément l'ordre public
c'est de la loi de la république et les
gens qui se radicalise et qui
n'appartiennent pas à la nation
française
évidemment pour plein de raisons on a
évoqué que ses intérieurs mais ça peut
être un manque de volonté
un manque de moyens ça peut être aussi
des difficultés on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler
expulsé sur des territoires en guerre en
libye ou en syrie
les gens qui sont arrivés son sol
national et légèrement difficile vous en
conviendrez avec moi mais il ya aussi
des français nés en france parfois de
parents français parfois français
j'aimerais pas parler comme vous parlez
de temps en temps mais le sénateur mais
depuis très longtemps parfois plus
depuis plus longtemps que ma propre
famille qui sont allés en syrie
qui se sont convertis et qui commettent
des attentats ignobles
donc oui il ya des étrangers radicalisé
mais éliminer les étrangers n'amènera
pas la radicalisation monsieur sénateurs
[Musique]